pas première il est 18h15 ce soir c'est
la dernière de culture première pour la
saison mais il a toujours en pleine
forme c'est jean paul vella bonsoir
bonsoir lucas bonsoir et bienvenue dans
culture première la dernière de la
saison quatre invités et louise de
jeunes de 34 ans qui sort son premier cd
au semestre prochain mais pas un inconnu
dans le monde de la danse nous
découvrirons quelques titres dans ce
magazine
ça sent les vacances certains s'envole
pour la france ou l'étranger d'autres
restent dans l'île ils pourront rêver
voyager s'amuser grâce à l'opération
il était une fois les vacances du 6 au
21 juillet pour nous en parler rieul
latchoumy et luc rosello enfin jeunes
graffeurs parisien de 35 ans et devant
le mur bruno cochard est venu sans ces
bombes
le temps d'une interview il nous dira ce
qu'il peint ou pour qui et comment on
vit de sa passion et à la technique ce
soir vincent tijuana culture première
avec jean-paul medad
bienvenue à tous bonsoir et merci d'être
là c'est un plaisir de vous recevoir
notre premier invité a connu plusieurs
noms civilement c'est jovani louise le
danseur chorégraphe et metteur en scène
a porté le pseudonyme de miss tic
aujourd'hui à la veille de la sortie de
son premier cd dont je ne connais
toujours pas le nom certains de ces
mystiques
il a opté pour louise elle aux u13 aide
pourquoi autant de changements vont lui
poser la question pour soir alors
pourquoi autant de changements tout
simplement parce qu'en fait mystique
c'est un personnage vraiment qui avait
été créée pour les besoins d'un d'un
spectacle qui s'appelait superstar
tributes j'avais continué en fait avec
ce pseudo là parce que c'est dans ce
cadre là que j'avais été repéré par la
production de m6 pour la france a un
incroyable talent et c'est donc j'ai
continué la route avec 7
ce pseudo là et puis est arrivée cette
aventure musicale et au départ je devais
lui devait l'officialiser sous ce pseudo
et puis finalement j'ai commencé à
travailler avec une équipe une équipe
parisienne ont fait et qui m'a donné
quelques conseils en matière de
marketing de stratégie de communication
et de trouver véritablement que la
démarche artistique puisqu'on est sur un
album concept autour de l'acceptation de
soi et la tolérance le pseudo en fait
mystique était un peu trop faisait un
petit peu trop personnage il manquait
d'authenticité et ils m'ont conseillé
tout simplement de rechercher à quelque
chose d'un peu plus vrai d'un peu plus
moi et bah quoi d'autre que mon nom de
famille alors pour l'illustrer voilà
louise alors donc elle a eu très mal zfs
avait il une explication pour vous avez
pu vous appeler josé pas pierre paul ou
je dois trouver un autre nom d'artiste
non seulement parce que c'est mon nom de
famille et que quelque part bon ben
voila c'était marrant parce que j'ai un
nom de famille le nom de famille rhénan
voilà qui a un prénom féminin la base
donc j'ai juste enlever la langue dieu
parce que c'est vrai que je joue
pleinement sur l'ambiguïté je songe à on
va en parler et
et donc voilà alors donc plus
authentique que ça je pense que je
pouvais pas d'accord mais il ya quand
même une référence à votre peur je pense
que vous vouliez oui aussi parce que
c'est vrai que quand mon papa bon qui
est décédé aujourd'hui quand il a appris
en fait mon orientation sexuelle ça a
été un petit peu compliqué parce que
pour lui
comme j'étais le seul fils ont fait de
la famille j'ai de grandes soeurs pour
lui il allait le nom allait forcément se
perdre et c'est parce que les enfants
enfin je sais pas je vous passe les
détails aujourd'hui des filles peuvent
porter le nom de l'eau par oui non c'est
sûr oui mais bon à l'époque c'était pas
possible pour tous à l'époque c'était
pas comme ça et est donc bah le moins
utilisé c'est mon ami c'est un petit peu
comme lui rendre hommage à lui montré
que peu importe l'orientation sexuelle
c'est c'est quelque chose qui restera et
c'est une façon à moi pour moi de le
figer en fait vous pouvez vous jouer sur
l'ambiguïté parce que moi je pense que
volvo interview donc que vous êtes
sommes hélas aujourd'hui quand on vous
regarde d'ailleurs j'ai dit à mes
collègues
venez voir une belle femme d'un des
hostilités en studio oui oui bah en fait
si vous voulez c'est un combat aussi que
je mène depuis pas mal d'années de que
ce soit depuis le perdre le spectacle
super ça fait but on se tirait la
comédie musicale la jeunesse de dracula
ou où je jouais vraiment un personnage
androgyne avec tout un message de
tolérance derrière et c'est ça en fait
finalement a donné naissance à ce projet
de concept album qui prône justement ces
valeurs d'acceptation de soi et oui oui
complètement je pense que on est dans
une société où parfois il est difficile
en fait de dette tout simplement ce que
soi même et des ce qu'on a envie d'être
et parce qu'on est systématiquement
ranger dans une case et moi j'ai décidé
de jouer là dessus parce que parce que
je pense qu'à un moment donné il faut il
faut savoir donner un petit coup de pied
dans la fourmilière et faire évoluer les
mentalités vous l'avez fait en tous les
cas je peux vous de couteau s'établit au
moins deux de quatre invités qui sont
gays friendly
alors je suis absolument sûr je ne
dirais pas qui je suis pratiquement sûr
nas est parfait alors alors cet album
cet album dont 10 titres
onze titres ouais moi je dis oui mais
voilà il ya un petit morceau qui est
menée en traitant local y croire non non
non
et puis j'ai écrit entre temps donc on
est alors justement j'ai écouté j'ai
écouté les titres n'ont pas tous j'en
écoutais deux ou trois ou quatre membres
que m'avait envoyé ça justement ça
tourne quand même autour de cette
ambiguïté et autour de cette
reconnaissance de la différence de ceux
qui sont capables eux mans différents
exactement en fait si vous voulez c'est
plus un c'est un parcours de vie j'ai
voulu donc les chansons en fait seront
seront situés cité par dont une à une
non pas en numérotation 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 c'est haram et sa seront vraiment
s'inscrit dans un espèce de parcs ou dix
parcours de vie et au travers de ce
parcours en fait je décline les chansons
qui ont un lien entre elles alors oui on
a cette chanson qui parle de tolérance
et d'acceptation de soi et après on a on
a beaucoup de sujets mais après je ne
traite pas exclusivement de la
thématique du genre même si au travers
de mon image c'est sûr que c'est quelque
chose qui ressort nécessairement mais
moi j'ai aussi envie de passer un
message parce que c'est le message que
moi je reçois aussi des gens des
personnes qui ont quelques complexes
qu'ils soient physiques ou autre et qui
n'osent pas en fait les assumer et qui
se sentent mal dans leur peau et c'est
ça en fait que j'ai envie de passer
comme message c'est acceptons nous nous
mêmes parce que pour se faire accepter
des gens je pense véritablement qu'il
faut s'accepter soi-même et livres hors
commun de tous les communes temps nous
travailler sur cet album puisque vous
vous produisez plein de choses à part
moi vous n'êtes pas quelqu'un qui reste
et des chez vous à nantes que de la
musique se fasse ou les paroles tombe du
ciel
donc en même temps pour réparer cet
album ça fait ça fait 10 10 11 mois que
j'y travaille en fait réellement
et je prends le temps j'ai pas envie en
fait de sortir quelque chose pour sortir
c'est pour ça qu'au départ je devais je
devais le sortir au mois de mars
et finalement la reculer cette échéance
justement par rapport à ces rencontres
que j'ai pu faire et je me suis dit
autant
autant de points de son temps et sortir
un projet abouti que calais à la va-vite
et voilà quoi aujourd'hui vous dire bon
vous allez certainement essayer de faire
carrière au niveau national je suppose
si vous avez une équipe parisienne
d'ailleurs vous vous savez qu'un à 18,18
milou 180 milles derrière qui pousse et
que vous petit réunionnais alors je sais
pas ce que je dois te peut tirer d'une
petite reno nev
mais alors comme vous voulez moi je pars
du principe que justement on joue sur
l'ambiguïté l'om s'attend pas il faut
pas s'offusquer en fait rayonner ménage
mon salon vous alors vous réunionnais
comment vous arrivez là bas dans la
capitale
certaines gens qui font des choses que
vous écoutez sincèrement moi je n'ai pas
la prétention au fait d'être la nouvelle
star de demain je fais les choses
véritablement parce que parce que j'ai
des choses ont fait à dire parce que
j'ai véritablement envie de véhiculer
certains messages de tolérance via mon
art après ça plaira à certains ça ne
plaira pas à d'autres si je peux si je
peux écumé les scènes va bien sûr je le
ferai maintenant ce n'est pas enfin
c'est pas mon objectif de sortie vous
avez de vous voulez devenir
professionnel ou pas non c'est pas mon
objectif c'est un boulot à côté j'ai un
boulot j'ai la chance de travailler dans
le domaine culturel aujourd'hui gémit
quand même beaucoup d'années à y arriver
j'ai un boulot qui me permet aujourd'hui
de payer mes factures et et dans lequel
je m'éclate accessoirement donc voilà
aujourd'hui la la la la partie
artistique reste sûrement une passion
que j'exploite mais c'est pas sais pas
j'espère pas en vivre en fait où on peut
savoir ce que vous faites dans nos vues
je m'occupe en fait d'un projet qui
s'appelle demos c'est le dispositif
d'éducation musicale et orchestrale à
vocation sociale qui est porté par la
cité des arts est qui et qui en fait
donne accès à l'apprentissage de la
musique à des enfants de milieux
populaires donc ensuite 99 enfants
répartis sur tout le territoire
l'insigne d'or donc si vous êtes a cité
des arts voudrait connaître ce qui est
en face de vous certainement on n'a pas
le cas encore parce qu'il a il a graffé
en moi et l'agrafé lui me sens sur le
mur pas encore il n'est pas encore connu
alors celui là doit donc au pouvoir j'ai
invité alors s'il n'ya pas encore il a
pas qu'au graffer sur le mur de la cité
des arts c'est incroyable bon c'est pas
grave on reporte tout à l'heure une
okocha alors donc vous ne vous êtes pas
si vous avez une ambition je ne faisais
pas une ambition nationale
alors comment ça se présente si vous
avez des parts et là vous avez une
équipe quitte à paris vous qui êtes ici
alors comment on fait pour travailler à
des contrats aujourd'hui en fait je
pense qu'un formidable outil qui
s'appelle internet
mais ce jeu voilà un nom mais on
s'appelle en fait on travaille on est on
s'appelle on peut échanger par mail et
voilà donc c'est ça marche assez bien de
nos jours le premier titre vous m'avez
envoyé des titres moi j'ai pas choisi
peut-être que vous voulez peut-être en
train de ce soir c'est que vous voulez
c'est celui qui vous a parlé le plus en
fait oui moi c'est un petit peu à la
croche j'écoute si ça me plaît et puis
des paroles tout ça ça me plaît je fasse
pas je passe pas obligatoire le numéro
alors qu'est-ce que vous avez choisi
comme numéro 1 vous sur votre cd comme
numéro un et il sa figure pas dans les
titres alors pourquoi la smac est désolé
non non non le numéro un ne figure pas
de réussite q quels jeux vous a envoyé
malheureusement on vous est aussi
danseur c'est avait commencé comme ça
oui mais chorégraphes ont fait mais vous
êtes vous êtes autodidacte vous êtes à
l'aise qu'ils avaient fait 95 ch de dix
dates j'ai monté pas mal de projets en
fait j'ai eu je viens vraiment du milieu
associatif
j'ai commencé le bal pire on va le dire
quand même puisque je suis pas écoute
dans certainement
et donc en fait j'ai commencé à l'âge de
13 ans dans le milieu associatif et j'ai
évolué je suis toujours dans le milieu
associatif aujourd'hui à 34 euros les
vrais péter toujours à bellepierre
je répète toujours la même pièce avec la
troupe vous avez vous autres combien
c'est fluctuant ça dépend des projets
par exemple assure le dernier projet sur
lequel on a travaillé la jeunesse de
dracula on était presque une trentaine
d'artistes aujourd'hui sur la partie
dans son nez une douzaine je pense
d'accord je pose une colle à ceux qui
sont autour de la table vous savez ce
que c'est qu'un unique en europe à
allier creuse et là on y croise les
doigts et on n'y va pas du tout jeu des
mille euros le jeu des mille euros
nombreuses okocha latchoumy non plus du
tout à la danse est un loup garou
voilà c'est le véritable nom lycanthrope
il a fait une comédie musicale qui
s'appelle le lycanthrope et pourquoi
avoir fait ça à l'époque en fait j'avais
envie de traiter la thématique des des
empires des des loups garous et c'est à
dire cela dit voilà il ya trop donc je
suis parti sur le loup garou et puis on
a écrit une histoire une histoire un peu
rocambolesque qui se passait à la
réunion est finalement logique entre
ville et la cd lui est d'accord celui
qui fait les photos de quoi là l'album
sortira qu'en parce qu'on vous avez dit
second semestre chez wagon qui revêtent
logiquement ce sera entre à mon avis on
m'accepte d'accord alors on va écouter
le premier extrait pendant toute
l'émission et coûtera donc 3 3 extraits
donc des chansons qu'on m'avait envoyé
est le premier extrait donc c'est vous
qui les avez composé toutes les chansons
chanson musique par écrit écrite la
composition c'est pas de moi y en a une
en fait qui a été composée par sandrine
bélier et hakim qui sont des réunionnais
avec qui j'ai eu l'occasion de
travailler sur un jeu nationale fut là
et ensuite sinon j'essaie du lisible
j'ai fait appel en fait à des
producteurs extérieurs
mais après les textes soit 100 de mon
temps on écoute marché
[Musique]
dédié cette pression imminent qui
jugeait qui commentent nos choix nos
convois sont et du froid sa tâche est
sans cesse à cet espoir qu'ils laissent
leurs convictions mais hélas front
renversé leurs voisins il m'a dit rampe
et j'ai rampé dans ce monde où les
regards compte quelque chose m'a bloqué
j'ai levé les yeux et chercher bombe
accrochée blessé juste avant les
survivants comme un déclencheur pour
m'appelle le différend la chose le
trouble fête
bel hommage est un trou où je puisse
mettre ma tête reprendre défense pour
que je puisse les affronter le plus fier
dans la nuit comme le font les dépenses
tu là
me ressourcer pour une autre vision du
combat
pour que la vie tué
ses charmes
ouais
tonton coeur de son niveau de jeu
marchez marchez notre sens n'est pas un
pur des ragots les rats et vie ne sont
quelques la boue sur je me suis pas un
clown ma différence est uniquement
scriptum c'est prouvé depuis le
jurassique
j'ai tissé l'étendard j'ai monté le
drapeau j'arrive et je revendique
nous sommes tous égaux et si tu ne crois
pas c'est que tu ne comprendra jamais
que rien ne sert de courir le seul but
est arrivé pour ces instants fragiles et
dans le thé venger infantile et guider
vers ton exil
on craint vaso mon vin le dîner
d'introduire les ego
qui prend l'eau vivre tes choix sans foi
ni loi où le verset le karma marché
là
marché pour notre vision tu coupes
comment que la vie dieu
si charles a donc c'était le premier
extrait de cette émission giovanni
louise merci en tout cas d'être venu oui
alors je précise juste que celle-ci en
fait c'était une maquette il y en a deux
en fait que j'ai enregistrés ont déjà en
studio donc voilà et c'est un featuring
en fait avec warren ce qui ce monsieur
waouh c'est quelqu'un et warren beatty
ouais c'est son pseudo sinon il
s'appelle laurent dans la vie est en
fait c'est qu'elle est c'est quelqu'un
qui est de saint benoît et et qui me
suit depuis depuis pas mal de temps et
que je remercie au passage merci
beaucoup
culture première sur réunion 1ère luc
rosello riolacci bonsoir vous êtes
respectivement directeur du centre
dramatique de l'océan indien saint denis
dit théâtre du grand marché et vous
directeur de la salle guy alphonsine à
saint-andré du creusot vous êtes le
petit nouveau si je puis m'exprimer
ainsi ré latchoumy l'aîné lors cela
mérite des explications
en 2005 le centre d'intervention
culturelle le cic de saint-andré la
salle de spectacle des avirons créé il
était une fois les vacances en 2010 est
le théâtre du grand marché et le théâtre
sous les arbres viennent rejoindre les
sept autres partenaires disséminés aux
quatre coins de l'île relais tschoumy 12
ans ça a été facile de convaincre les
autres de venir s'intégrer au groupe
disons que notre discours de départ est
le suivant sa coupe pas être dans une
affirmation le spectacle pour tous nos
fans d'accès du spectacle pour tous à
tous de démocratisation de la culture
et puis d'avoir un moment donné dans
l'année toutes les salles qui ferment et
ne pas proposer ne pas voir d'offres
pour le 1 le public disponible et les
familles les enfants et donc avec ma
collègue des avirons milliyet
c'était en 2005 avait décidé de réagir
et de dire qu'il faut faire une offre à
ce moment là en faveur du public là ils
pensent que tout naturellement peu à peu
les ans les autres responsables de ça
les autres qui se préoccupe de sa de
cette démocratisation de l'accès à la
culture
petit à petit il est venu naturellement
d'un petit peu me dis pas combat mais
enfin le dimanche
la marche et du premier coup vous êtes à
saint-andré cantona avec les avirons
quand on va mettre ça en place la
première fois
oui mais pense que la ville avait une
attente de la part d'un peu de tout ce
public que millau disponible quand les
familles les enfants les jeux devaient
passer les mots quant au dispositif plus
disponibles d'accord c'est le public qui
peut pas partir mais c'est aussi peut
être un public défavorisé n'ont
peut-être pas bahia do faut pas dire
force et moi c'est un public défavorisé
il ya déjà le public encadré qui qui
étaient là les centres de vacances donc
forcément qui nourrit un intérêt tout de
suite pour ce genre de proposition et
puis après c'est à nous de faire la
démarche d'aller vers ce public comme la
cible et dès le départ puisque le sous
titre de la manifestation c'est quand
même les voyages de ceux qui restent
donc notre préoccupation à nous c'était
voilà les les enfants des cités des
quand y ait des écarts faire en sorte
que nous voit dans nos salles à publics
n'ont pas l'habitude de vent sur le
reste de l'année c'est vrai encore
justement pendant les vacances et là
cette année c'est donc du 6 au 21 juin
des faits à peu près 15 jours des pleins
en général une expérience ou de savoir
ça de l'e pl1 ou alors parfois la colle
des trous sur les spectacles les plats
les attendus et justement le un des
problèmes que nous vivent à c'est que
petit à petit on veut dire que ceux qui
ne sont pas encore parties viennent au
spectacle
donc c'est un public habitué qui est
toujours là les cantons partis ailleurs
et qui donc rempli parce que jeune à
l'habitude du spectacle donc il va pas
lui réserve
ça se fait au détriment de ce public qui
l'avait ciblé ou des plans ce public un
peu qui reste un petit peu
en dehors du circuit du spectacle vivant
ce public là il tenterait un petit peu
de nous échapper vais pas concurrence
quand même à deux grandes manifestations
comme ça le cette erreur n'a rien à voir
nous est pas là dans chacun de ces
événements n'a sa place et on a besoin à
la fois du tempo de ce qu'il faut
quitter rade de ce que chacun peut
proposer et nous ne la une place précise
nous la mi krwa occuper un vide
et puis ça se vit depuis 13 ans à 13 ans
et c'est un bon chef et puis me veut
dire s'il continue c'est que vraiment la
commune et à la lan demande que j'ai
déjà envie de 20 heures d'une poigne de
vendre les gens il ya aussi une réaction
positive me croit comprendre de la part
des collègues si aujourd'hui le grand
manche et il rejoint c'est pas comme ça
par amitié de l'uff auriol pas du tout
si ça va au delà de ça et en plus il
faut noter que le grand marché c'est
quand même la ville de saint denis sera
justement
oui si le théâtre sous les arbres des
cidres devenir look le théâtre sous les
arbres démarre avec une nouvelle équipe
qui est encore fragile
c'est parce que sans doute que ce que
nous propose à travers le festival fait
sens essaye d'aller plus loin que la
simple programmation d'un certain nombre
de spectacles alors dû creuser mais
pourquoi le tas de commentaires après
tant de temps avant m dans le dispositif
et ben justement me pose la question
gérard bibeau c'est la question la pose
à moi à cause à col saint denis n'est
pas présent dans le dans le dispositif
il était une fois les vacances donc
voilà pose à moi la question moi la
cause est kréyol et puis après la diva
via war halo alon kozé on les parties
nous la cause et puis
sani la rentrer dans le train que ça
dure marché c'est 20 le comment le jeu
d'abord une époque saint denis étaient
présents un choix riols oui avec le par
là que ça voilà une époque samedi était
présent et après ça ni s'est retiré il
ya deux choses qui font que le théâtre
du grand marché a souhaité rejoindre
cette cette dynamique collégiale parce
qu'il faut aussi peut-être rien mais je
te laisserai le faire parce que c'est
pâques l antériorité préfère expliquer
comment ça fonctionne comment comment le
comment s'organise en interne aussi pour
alors oui alors effectivement bien alors
j'ai eu une fois un fort enjeu de
solidarité professionnelle dans cette
affaire qui fait que que tout est mis en
commun il ya d'abord l'organisation
la sélection des spectacles effet dans
la collégialité chacun fait des
propositions on se réunit l'ensemble des
salles qui vont participer à l'édition n
se réunit en année n - m
un voisin commence à discuter
programmation qu'est-ce qu'on n'arrête
le spectacle vers quoi on vint comment
on fait en sorte qu'on respecte un petit
peu là la charade conseil imposées en
matière de 2,2 variété de spectacles de
diversité des compagnies donc ça on se
réunit à la pension décide tout le monde
enfants et tout le monde a droit à une
voix égales par ailleurs
ensuite il ya une mutualisation des
moyens et notre force à nous quand un
moment donné sur un lieu il ya une
difficulté à pouvoir suivre l'ensemble
des propositions faites noir en janot
pour que globalement ne trouvera des
solutions pour celui ou celle qui peut
se trouver en difficulté la solidarité
alors donc où la pâte y voit lui sa
maladie j'adore ça coût faible environ
dans le train et où la rentrée de l'été
aussi simple que ça il est aussi simple
que ça justement à cause le à cause de
bonnes valeurs dans le façon le façon
bonne professionnelle lie organisation
donc le bonnes valeurs là mais trouve
les intéressants il est intéressant
parce que bien sûr d'annales l'objectif
de il était une fois les vacances mais
aussi un espèce mon envie de dire
position professionnelle que les super
super intéressant que même nous
pourraient nous pour imaginer à d'autres
moments qu'il était dur il répond à une
vision d'une politique qu'une commune de
la culture à la réunion et puis ce qu'il
ya d'intéressant avec le grand marché
c'est que voir comment nous peut faire
asseoir à côté une structure comme
le centre dramatique et une salle comme
celle des avirons qui est en régie
municipale directe une autre comme celle
de fée mazine qui est une association
sans lieu à une structure comme la salle
alphonsine qui actuellement n'a pas de
lieu est amené à a investi à différents
coins et recoins de la commune de
saint-andré comment des sections price
mais oublie pas par exemple les bambous
en boucle et poussez la porte à nos
capés aussi à la porte des bombes ou non
les bambous et pleinement d'aidé au
contraire valoir que viser la pomme but
2-2 les excès de notre salle ah oui oui
oui mais sur un vrai projet de réfection
des structures très diverses certaines
formes fragile et qui commence à se
mettre en route me parler littérature is
able d'autres un petit peu pris dans des
considérations peut-être municipal n'est
pas dans le mauvais sens du monde dans
le bon sens du mot comme la plaine des
palmistes
voilà donc faire faire un saut tout ce
monde là autour d'une table et m à part
égale dans un projet qui défend un même
objectif
il croit à ces nobles parce que voilà
c'est ce qui fait que les gens on arrive
à et il ya un teint de cette année luc
rosello ou pas dans cette émission une
fois des vacances cet été une fois les
vacances non ya pas deux il n'y a pas de
thème
il n'y a pas de thème particulier enfin
ce me semble mais par contre une
une forme d'exigence de qualité avec des
objets artistiques qui qui s'adresse
d'une part au jeune public mais qui sont
aussi attractif pour les parents qui
accompagneront les les enfants il faut
s'y essaie aussi on pas l'actrice tea
vite il faut quand même parler du prix
or justement parlons-en parce que les
abris quand même raisonnable
oui c'est plus que raisonnable mais oui
c'est 2 2 euros l'entrée et ce qui est
important c'est que ces deux euros sur
l'ensemble du territoire avec l'ensemble
des structures qui participent à il
était une fois les vacances ça fait déjà
débat démocratique l'accès du spectacle
à tout le monde passe par une politique
tarifaire qui sera vraiment à portée de
tous
alors ça veut dire que vous êtes vous
êtes prisonnier votre succès légendaires
se précipiter à ce tarif là pour pouvoir
venir voir les spectacles donc
certaines personnes peut-être pas tout
oui c'est un des problèmes il dit à
leurs jeunes à résoudre c'est comment
faire que cette accessibilité ne profite
pas là où on ne l'attendait pas mais
aille vraiment bien ce qu'on nous veut
toucher parce qu'on y voit pas donc plus
de bananes on ne vient pas parce que les
autres donc l'obliger à tous le monde
alors que ben oui parce que c'est moi
discrimination cette année alors on va
regarder un petit peu le spectacle vasco
nena il commence pour les tout petits
petits trois ans déjà la même un an à 1
n'ont pas tous à peine on a deux
spectacles l'un il vient d'afrique du
sud à cet accord de gestion et l'autre
micro qui vient de l'isère les
attractions extraordinaire de la femme
chapiteau alors j'ose et ajustements das
d'afrique du sud un en anglais les nains
un soutien orale ou alors c'est une mode
de la manipulation
c'est pas en anglais c'est de la
manipulation c'est du mime presque voilà
mais combien même c'était en anglais
pense pas que c'est noble sac mon père
matthias bal tamoul millau mik
mais comme en mal d'amour mais il ya pas
le tam tam il ya un petit peu écrit par
chalmé mi aime bien le bal tamoul
d'accord ok alors donc just et a donc de
1 an à trois ans où il a vu le la le
spectre spectacle parfaitement utilisé
des pelles repéré par nos collègues
de tte masina saint pierre qui se rend
régulièrement d'ailleurs sur des
festivals en afrique du sud
lundi nyan odette chaque compagnie a
accueilli cette compagnie là une forte
production est très bon spectacle
patchwork et donc n'ont pas hésité à
remettre le couvert
luc rosello et aux quotas ou à la houle
a choisi ou pour cette année alors
comment elle est vraiment le bleusaille
dans le train la voie à l'arrivée
vraiment dernier dernier la queue
minutes comme il dit samba et donc je le
dis là que mimi tmo bonne camarade avait
vite de la ville de choisir spectacle
mais dans le lapin posé un problème en
fait pas ce qu'il y faisait mais faisons
confiance et moi la diva ok je te l'a
choisi ça puis voilà là dedans
voilà que le grand marché nous là nous
la trouve notre place et nous l'avons
choisi de trois spectacles pour diffuser
alors que ça n'en vois qu'on respecte à
d'autres grands marchés justement aux
insomnies l art grand marché n'aura
ti-jean pêcheurs ouais voilà ça c'est un
compagnie locale
après
nora les attractions extraordinaire de
la femme chapiteau parce que c'est un
thème du spectacle met tout de suite les
affaires à la moins sûre les espaces
sous la jupe un madame madame donc là
commence bien donc tout de suite voilà
il est vrai qu'il va beaucoup de chance
c'est tellement bien sûr mais c'est pour
d'autres j'ai un oui bien évidemment
voila voila puis nous lâcher choisi
madame madame gasca alors plus probable
est voté par 204 voix là ne la choisit
madagascar nous la nouvelle choisi
exprès nous fait ça le samedi enfin en
juste voilà enfin fin d'après midi c'est
social façon invite aussi nous bandent
voisin le grand marché que qu'il
travaille dans le groupe voilà tous les
gages du bazar gas donc aussi nous voilà
nous va nous rendre voisin parce que et
que je dis bien que son enfance aux
siens façon pour le grand marché
travaillent aussi ce territoire là parce
que même si même si nous les oies quand
on côté causes sur le public défavorisé
en fait on n'est pas obligé le plus le
moun les dans des situations économiques
difficiles pour que l'iss
il envoyait pas son enfant au causse
comtal spectacle en fait toi c'est de le
balader encore hazard et aka d'euros un
spectacle à 18 et évidemment les sûr que
c'est plus facile évidemment mais par
exemple me suis vraiment il fait pas
longtemps il fait pas longtemps mal au
grand marché
mëme peut dire où conan a beaucoup
d'enfants et la même beaucoup de mou ni
travail aux autres grands marchés que la
jamais rentrer dans le rang dans le 4
mai - d'accord donc l'idée c'est aussi
ceux ci travaillent sur relation là donc
voilà pourquoi il a choisi madagascar
mais pas seulement pour le bazar
malgache mais aussi pour pour tout ce
que vous tous qui veuille bien sûr bien
sûr il sait pas ce qu'il fait c'est un
aboutissement à la réunion mais voilà
louise est bonne au cauchemar vous êtes
déjà entré dans
du grand marché une fois où il a
longtemps moi je crois que la dernière
fois c'était il ya une semaine et demie
en fait je suis allé voir le spectacle
de fin d'année de l'école joinville en
fait ils traitent même séverine là la
piste ah oui la piste est plus beau
short stack a l'occasion me rappelle kim
des collèges bien rire latchoumy donc
coup d'envoi le 6,6 ou mi juillet
s'achève le 21 on peut rappeler les
salles où ça va ça va se passer en
dehors du grand marché qui rappelle
alors aux épargnants ont fait le tour de
l'île la plaine des palmistes la salle
guy agénor saint benoît le théâtre les
bambous saint-andré la salle guy
alphonsine saint denis
le grand marché le port leucate sous les
arbres saint-paul l'espace leconte de
lisle les avirons la salle georges
brassens saint pierre fait mazine je
trouve que ça pierrefonds saint joseph
l'auditorium ary payet me crois que
c'est un fait le tour
ok entre la wii chacune et chacune des
salles il faut le dire propose à côté
des spectacles
alors c'est un ensemble d'actions ne
plusieurs mètres un peu le petit plus
qui permet un peu de nourrir l'intérêt
des spectateurs peut-être
pas habitué pour un petit peu ce qu'ils
vont alors se croiser ce sera quoi le
plus grand marché du chrono assez une
colle dans mac os laoudar cash
oui cela fait tout de suite et avait
trop fait il y aura du maquillage ou pas
vous au grand marché du maquillage je ne
sais pas pour les enfants par exemple
non n'ira pas mais que de clichés de
poncifs monsieur mais là devant dès
qu'on réunit des enfants il faut les
mecs un peu partout et maintenant
partout des maquisards et les structures
proposent pouvoir propose des actions
qui sont sensiblement différentes
tous les clichés qu'on impose à ces
pauvres marmaille
merci à tous les cas d'être venu tous
les deux nous parlait donc de
l'opération il était une fois les
vacances pour ceux qui restent les
voyages de ce qui va seulement ils
peuvent s'amuser ils peuvent rire ils
peuvent même temps c'est aussi tout ce
qui s'apparente pour d'émotion sur bon
ils peuvent tomber aussi porter ses vols
sur votre et saufs se maquiller sort se
maquiller sociale choisie
bon vous n'aurez pas droit parce que
l'on peut pas déjà là strictement et
lavoirs et louise un magnifique
maquillage et parfois et louis se vautre
aussi peu de temps en temps c'est pour
ça qu'elle chante will you for me
[Musique]
chez passer le temps passé l'instant
c'est moi
peu de ces fiers pour exister
le sochaux poursuit show l'espère
[Musique]
mais
il faut former
[Musique]
info l'homme feuillus j'ai passé tant
magie n'est qu'en jours seulement tu
m'attendrait lylison et d'effacer ses
restos je chérissais ne te voilà
devant moi brio tous ces mois juste eu
ta voix mais toi tu ne me touches pas tu
me vois
cette fois will you for laughs hormis
donc un des extraits donc de l'album de
oui ça peut cet album on n'a pas de vie
j'ai pas encore décidé je pense car
enfin moi parce qu'un nom d'album c'est
super important
on en fait la fin alors qu'est ce que
disait d'aller creuser nos noms et les
excités comme j'ai cru le comprendre au
début de l'audience une stratégie là des
départs l'akoya des voyages bon allez
avant de recevoir notre prochain invité
je vous invite à redécouvrir un peintre
rayonner un peu oublié parce qu'il
s'était mis en retrait depuis plusieurs
années dany dans le psychédélique était
dernièrement au salon de la maison pour
son retour en douceur il a décidé de se
bouger culture première sur réunion 1ère
il faut changer sans cesse il faut se
remettre sans cesse en question
aujourd'hui il faut il faut il faut que
l'exposition ne m'a pas hésiter c'est
pas gagné il faut il faut sortir du lot
il faut explorer d'autres ressources il
faut être toujours unis vers d'autres
univers il faut attirer l'attention des
gens il faut il faut que qu'une solution
ma fille m'a appelée gens d'en arriver
là avec d'autres supports et je pense
que c'est important de ne pas se
cantonner à des formes classiques voix
la voix voir des peintures trop
classique donc
alors je souhaitais autre nom de la
maison alors est-ce que les gens sont
surpris des gens sont très choqués sont
sont heureux de voir et j'ai de bonnes
retombées des gens qui trouvent ça c'est
magnifique
après après ces deux lorrains dans dans
la masse de gens qui fassent il ya des
sensibilités du pictural et soutenons
pictural donc d'euros la baie
dans l'ensemble c'est une solution
intéressante que les gens aiment bien en
général
est-ce que ça se traduit par des agents
ça ça se traduit pas déjà chargé
au fil du temps où également par des
retours en atelier la prochaine
exposition dany dandin ce sera quand et
où
mais pour l'instant je ne sais pas je ce
sera pour l'année prochaine c'est sûr
mais je cherche un lieu adéquat pour
faire une solution vraiment d'allié
d'andenne et non plus être dans un sens
ça dans la maison quoi il aurait combien
de toiles exposées pour cent soit c'est
qu'il est prêt après ça dépend de
dimensions de la delà de l'espace de
solution je compte m'en maximum une
trentaine de toiles c'est jouable mais
il faut au minimum un an à 200 travail
oit culture première avec jean-paul
medad
18h51 je le connais peu de lui sauf
qu'il est nette
a colombes il ya 35 ans mais c'est le
plus régulier des parisiens il arrive à
l'aréna l'âge de 9 ans à 14 ans bruno
caisse cochard découvre le graphe grâce
à un cousin de l'hexagone à croire
qu'ils sont tous exilés et donne son
premier coup de bombe à 17 ans à venoix
depuis 2009 il est pro son fief l'est et
plus particulièrement saint benoît c'est
exact exactement alors que j'ai tout dit
ou presque de la carrière du graff les
grandes lignes un peu puissant alors
qu'est ce qui a donné c'est quoi le
déclic en dehors du fait que bon vous
êtes peut-être là pour aider west est
juste même une passion c'est juste je
voulais voir comment comment ça se passe
et ce monde à la base ce n'est pas
forcément le monde du graff on va dire
c'était plutôt le milieu du hip hop
convoitises plus généralement avant le
graphe il ya eu la musique la danse du
nom c'est aussi avons peur d'aller vite
et bien longtemps et que voilà de fil en
aiguille à force d'essayer d'essayer ben
voila je me suis mis dedans sans le
savoir sans le vouloir non plus avec et
qu'est ce qui vous inspire
les dessins déjà jus il faut aimer le
dessin des gens ça à la base destiné on
va dire à van de graaff et
déjà après voilà c'est venu au fur et à
mesure c'est ce qu'il va dire un aimant
le dessin est mon lit pop mais voilà je
pense que les deux sont rejoints et ça
ça de d'el paso du graff et les thèmes
favoris pas forcément fin pas des thèmes
on va l'aider style est plutôt mon
volume en passant je suis plus au visage
par exemple que lettrage
moi j'aimerais qu'on doit faire c'est en
seconde et lettrage moi c'est plus visa
visage des paysages que l'étrange alors
si je vous dis salvador d'années ça vous
parle oui pourquoi on concède un artiste
oui d'accord je sais mais vous avez fait
un graphe je trouve
oui salvador dali ben c'était lui à sa
voix il va chercher
vous n'avez pas un souci là à se lasser
des pantins barber shop
j'ai des corps pas mal de dos le cou
comme ça barbershops salon coiffure
maison il y avait des gros ciseaux si
c'est exactement voilà il manque le pain
bah ouais j'ai pas mis encore l'oubli
bon alors si je j'ai noté des frères je
me suis amusé à regarder votre page
facebook
bien sûr je n'étais des mots des phrases
dont je vais vous les donnez vous me
direz ce que ça évoque pour vous big up
festival la semaine prochaine alors
diffèrent il y à brens le big festival
semaine prochaine et je suis sélectionné
pour faire le concours en trois temps
comprend degroof
vous en avez déjà gagné ou pas oui où ça
ici en france ici j'ai fait le concours
pour le crédit agricole
c'était un coucou interne et du coup je
gagnais monnaies a gagné au final donc
alors vous allez le coco vous êtes trop
depuis 2009 c'est ce que ça veut dire
que vous vous êtes enfin vous allez
essayer de vous en vivez bien sûr mais
vous partez à l'étranger vont porter en
france vous partez josé pas dans la zone
pour l'heure pas encore on va dire
j'adorerais faire ça mais en fait je me
suis plutôt cantonné enfin j'ai pas
voulu mais là on va dire je suis plutôt
le graffeur va dire sur commande
c'est à dire que je bosse principalement
pour des gens pour le particulier maison
tout ça c'est vrai que j'ai pas le à
notoriété de certains grimpés à la
réunion qui peuvent voyager
et qui peuvent exposer la cité des arts
détonnants donc j'attends mon tour la
semaine prochaine vous savez qu'à
l'origine vous été invité en même temps
que jess mais qu'il a décliné parce
qu'il est pro de l'avion donc quand je
peux plus d'invités et donc du coup je
sais pas qui sont ces voix là si vous
voulez vous devenir célèbre alors si je
mets pas n'a jamais mis aussi barber
shop
évidemment vous en avez parlé case de
bras panon casse de bras panon
ouais je travaille tous les jours sur
radio c'est pour ça que je trouvais dans
un local un atelier à bras panon ci qui
fait du maloya et on va durer je suis
tous les jours là bas c'est mon atelier
maintenant qu'est-ce que vous avez
dessiné ce show case rien ah si si j'ai
fait fonds marins avec une baleine et
quelques personnages du mal à l'admettre
mais regardez je fais mon boulot et si
je vous dis au salvador dali on en a
parlé si je vous dis gay pride passants
parlent pas à pas comptés sur votre page
facebook il ya plein de village de ya
plein de photos de la gay pride à paris
de juin j'ai pas trop ou pas du tout un
impact futur bar à côté je regardais je
ferais des photos seins et vous
désormais voir quelqu'un piloter votre
compte
bon trêve de plaisanterie dit rien n'a
pas dans un carré du cern
beaucoup de gens comme vous qui vivent
de
du graff à la réunion non je pense pas
la langue la plupart c'est vraiment une
fille me semblent justes même pas ah non
non non elle travaille à la mairie de
saint denis et elle fait ça à côté leur
belle voix grave fut réellement
professionnellement quasi professionnel
c'est quoi là j'ai un numéro siret qui
met paiement va dire de travailler pour
les collectivités les mairies tout ça
mais je vous fait rien d'autre à côté ça
je venais ici avant si je travaillais
tout est commercial avons par exemple
voilà va dire que c'est vraiment depuis
les 2010 que ça a commencé vraiment être
vraiment régulier voire journalier
aujourd'hui moi j'ai des appels tous les
jours facebook messenger et ou de
clients de toute l'île et j'espère plus
loin si possible comme desautels
shalamar inch'allah et vous prenez
sherbrooke au sort vous avez fort
justement quels sont les mêmes de modèle
pour une demande de plus quand j'ai un
visage si j'allais particuliers dans
leurs usages et les âges et très souvent
des coûts pour les chambres des enfants
c'est tout ce qui est des animés ça
c'est une quotidienne et les
collectivités inclusivité c'est par
exemple décoration de stade par exemple
moi j'ai déjà fait le terrain de foot de
saint benoît de saint-andré après ses
succès d initiation pour les enfants
aussi à en demande très souvent là pour
vous là pour aider les vacances tous à
s'abonner à un bras panon sait attendre
et zut je fais pas mal de sons qu'elle
est la plus grande fresque que vous avez
réalisé à ce jour et où à ce jour c'est
le terrain
s'attendrait atteindrait baby la rivière
j'ai 80 mètres de long wahou c'était
pour eux
jeux des îles et quand même temps vous
avez pris pour faire ça j'ai pris un
mois et demi avec des enfants âgés de 8
à 10 ans on a peint 80 mètres de mur
avec des gamins de 10 ont alors
travaillé avec ce genre de produit
aujourd'hui c'est les polices ne sont
plus toxiques si si si ça va de la
peinture mais après comme tout comme
tout produit comme ce matin il faut se
protéger jeux med mais même à ce que les
gants tout ça ramène chez particulier
c'est toujours eu des bâches pour
protéger les mêmes tout ça s'ils sont
obligés de produits vous vous éclatez à
fond